what a good story this is childhood
sweethearts who reconnect 20 years later
only to realize they were meant for each
other in the story I would be the evil
white American husbands standing in the
way of Destiny shut up past lives is a
love story that spans over 20 years in
two different continents across sort of
Pacific
Ocean it's quite autobiographical in
some way
it is very much an adaptation of my life
into a love story he was just this kid
in my head for such a long time I think
I just missed him did he miss you it's
asking questions about what's possible
in one
lifetime you get to see a progression of
a human's life so it's expansive but it
also has tremendous heart and focus to
it just as I am a product of both
eastern and western way of thinking I
wanted past to have a relationship to
both
[Music]
worlds Seline had such a singular vision
for this story it just seemed very
obvious there was a potential to make
something that felt true to her life
experience we're exploring this idea of
childhood love how does that play out
what parts of that can still exist and
can remain true into adulthood I think
we do get a feeling of a longlasting
almost soulmate like kind of connection
it's really hard to describe in words
because you just feel it when you're
with somebody that moment when we turn
and we see each other for the first time
and so many years we wanted to capture
what that could really feel
like here
[Music]
all
that moment before we meet at the pond
we are vulnerable together but don't
have any dialogue so it's like how deep
can I go showing that inner life only
Through The Eyes which are the only
parts of the nervous system that are
openly exposed to the real world and
thereby have a window to your heart and
your
emotion what
Seline she asked that we not make
physical contact and having not half
that until that moment that the audience
is experiencing that with us together
those kind of reactions I felt like were
really visceral that moment became
pressurized because of
that this wordless exchange that is full
body and painful and miserable and also
electric and
dynamic
[Music]
the act of falling in love it was a
surprise it was a surprise to
[Music]
me I needed an actress who understood
the very complicated thing of speaking
in very different languages and being
able to be loved in different cultures
and Greta Lee has been everything that I
could have possibly imagined for a
partner for this journey partly because
she also exists in these liminalities
it's just that you make my life so much
bigger and know wondering if I do the
same thing for you the language
component of this film was a really big
deal for me it forced me to be
vulnerable in a way that I was deeply
uncomfortable with I'm just a girl from
Korea you know
there's something about being bilingual
it is so exposing that feeling of having
one foot in two different worlds is
something that is so complicated and
wonderful and also painful sometimes
like how to reconcile two totally
separate identities and this film was
requiring me to jump into it fully
w wow
and let's roll sound please
roll early in conversations with Seline
we sort of tossed around this idea of
Teo and I not being able to meet until
we absolutely had to and luckily we had
a crew and a team that helped facilitate
[Music]
that and that's us meeting for the first
time on film I think it works and also
it's just fun to be able to do these
little experiments as actors the first
time that the actors who played those
two characters met each other was my
favorite
time uh hi nice to meet you as through
who Nora is we're seeing Two Worlds and
two universes collapse upon each other
here we
go
the bar scene was crucial we took 2 days
to shoot one scene and arguably the
movie lives and dies on the success of
the bar scene and that was made
explicitly clear to us in the shooting
of it the Genesis of that scene was a
real life experience where Seline found
herself flanked by two men one her
husband and the other her childhood
sweetheart the profound experience of
sitting in the thresold between two men
who could know her so completely but in
two totally different ways so we really
took our time in terms of making sure we
could honor what that experience is
like I remember for me wanting these
Escape Routes I kept suggesting maybe I
go get a drink maybe I excuse myself to
go to the restroom maybe there's this he
kept trying to leave I kept trying to
leave because it was so awkward you know
trying to be honest and natural you keep
wanting to get out but Seline insisted I
stay there in the uncomfortable
awkwardness of the
scene
the way that I had to be as Nora with
Arthur as opposed to Hong is entirely
different and the physicality of that is
really specific that's one of the
essential ideas of this movie
based on seline's actual experience and
she could feel like a completely
different woman in the presence of each
of these men who know and love her so
differently and fully and completely
just talking about
you after 2 days of filming finally we
get to a point where Jung and Arthur are
sat alone and kind of have their manto
man talk if you will and I think that
buildup LED for tremendous energy and a
very Dynamic
scene to be Lov without being needed
which I think is very much an important
part of this film hessong is able to
love Nora without needing her that's
sort of how I feel about shooting in New
York
too it's impossible but you somehow do
it and it's always worth it to have the
chance to shoot the authentic New York
especially this present New York was
really exciting I know the crew and
everyone here who is from New York was
really excited to be shooting on the
streets feel that energy of New York
there's nothing like it especially when
you're working on 35mm film where you
know you have only like a limited amount
of takes so it kind of heightens the
stakes everyone was so concentrated and
focused the way in which Arthur is there
for Nora and requires the kind of
commitment that hes is not being asked
to give hasung throughout the film calls
naong and Arthur throughout his
existence in the film calls her Nora in
the middle of that Nora is making a
decision to be
Nora is so much more than a love story
it's a story about cultural identity
it's a story about change it's a story
about Connections and loss of
connections I was expecting it to have
the elements of being a romantic drama
but I can't believe how much this movie
has just become so much bigger than that
it's so much more expansive and it's
about our human capacity for love maybe
that capacity is much more boundless
than we ever
[Music]
knew they're Big Ideas I hope people can
like feel that in the way that we have
felt it in the making of
this